to them to them to them do do do do do
do do do do do
adios good hey what is going on YouTube
now recently subscriber Shawn neuen
asked what is your perspective when the
white people ask where are you from know
like where are you really from now for
me growing up I never really had that
question asked to me too much reason
being I grew up in South Sacramento
California which is actually incredibly
culturally diverse and if anything just
a little ghetto like if you ask somebody
where you're from where I grew up you
just might get a different answer excuse
me where are you from your mama's [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay I'm scared it's
interesting because we call that the
classic you're trying too hard not to be
prejudiced question and you know it's
actually lightweight kind of cute
because that person is actually trying
to engage in a conversation with you and
maybe just try to be your friend but
sometimes even though the intent is good
it still comes up culturally insensitive
right and probably the most anointing
for you is that it happens too
frequently so for those of you out there
that want to ask that question here's a
bit of advice if you initially ask
somebody where they're from and they say
California take that answer and don't go
any further please I beg you do not have
Asian country Tourette's where you
constantly guess where they are from
Beijing Japan Korea Thailand Laos
Cambodia what no yes maybe I'm so sorry
but in all honesty dude if you're asking
how to deal with this a little change in
perspective might help you to better
understand what's going on the reason
why they asked you where you're really
from this because they wanted that to be
the anchor point in the conversation
which was a topic that you two can go
ahead and go back and forth with value
Aska because 90% of the time even if you
do answer them and you tell them where
you're from they will probably follow up
with something like this where are you
from Korea yeah I [ __ ] love noodles
this [ __ ] you know what the funny thing
is that when people find out where
you're from they instantly try to
connect with you by telling you the food
that they ate from your culture and I
always wonder what type of reaction were
you expecting oh yes thank you
matcha pour the northern re it's just
weird friend because when you talk about
where you're from it's not like we try
to relate you know what you have for
dinner where are you from America Oh
peaceful Komaki Bernardo
I think TV and social media has [ __ ]
up this concept so bad is because people
watch what they see on TV about somebody
else's culture and they use that as a
conversation topic to go ahead and
relate to them well I saw Bizarre Foods
and these guys were eating camel dicks
oh here you go
brought you some Victor breakfast but
all in all the moral the story is don't
be so offended with somebody as ask you
about their culture just try to
understand where they're coming from and
if it still offends you say something if
not then I don't know what to tell you
you're just being a be pale my [ __ ]
body is what is the way my nipples so
hard hey what is going on YouTube
yes that was a topic suggested by Sean
newand remember you guys can go to my
facebook fan book page facebook fanpage
suggest topics ask questions as for life
advice submit articles whatever you want
me to talk about we will vlog about it
we will make it interesting we will make
it pop it I will see you all next time
remember every Wednesday and Sundays we
got videos coming at you you love me
yeah you do [ __ ] and probably can do
bhai he would you [ __ ] always got
bloopers cuz I can't say [ __ ] up maybe I
don't speak English